la mer noire à la mer absorbe la mère
prend la mer fait peur elle incarne un
univers froid sombre inconnu et donc le
vaisseau parfait dans de nombreuses
croyances pour transporter les morts
vers leur nouvelle demeure
pour cela elle est indissociable du
bateau navire qui apparaît sans prévenir
et emporte avec lui les trépassés qu'il
soit la barque de charon ou le panneau
ce breton des navires des morts
préexiste à toutes les légendes de
vaisseau fantôme et les ont probablement
inspiré les vaisseaux fantômes des
apparitions soudaines de navires vide
délabrés ou luminescents qui prennent le
pas au xviiie siècle sur les légendes de
sirènes et de léviathan si courante
durant le moyen-âge
si je vous parle du hollandais volant
vous connaissez sûrement au moins de nom
ce navire légendaire rendu populaire par
wagner ou pirates des caraïbes selon vos
centres d'intérêts il s'agirait d'un
vaisseau maudit ayant pactisé avec le
diable dans la deuxième moitié du xviie
siècle est condamné à errer sur les mers
depuis cette légende apparaît dans les
années 1790 et se développe dans la
littérature du 19e siècle dans une telle
diversité de supports et de témoignages
qu'il est difficile de remonter aux
origines de cette histoire c'est le
propre des légendes me direz vous et
c'est le cas de la plupart des légendes
tournant autour des vaisseaux fantômes
le calais ou tce par exemple est un
navire fantôme du folklore chilien qui
apparaîtrait illuminé au large de l'île
de chiloé et à bord duquel on entendrait
des sons de fête et de ses passagers
promis à une vie éternelle
difficile ici de se raccrocher à la
réalité puisque la légende en question
ne fait référence à aucun autre âge ce
n'est pas le cas du tricolore au tricot
lourd puisque la légende qui l'entourent
ferait référence à un vrai navire le 5
janvier 1937 l'équipage du causse tron
aurait aperçu un navire le tricot lourds
qui aurait disparu après les avoir longé
par babeau en vérifiant les cartes de la
région le capitaine aurait découvert la
mention du ms tricolore coulé à cet
endroit précis six ans plus tôt
malheureusement impossible de retrouver
des preuves du tricolore à ducos tron
dont les noms ne figurent que sur des
sites friands de légendes et de
paranormal
les mythes 2.0 on retrouve la même idée
avec le lady lovely bones ou goélette
qui se serait échouée en 1748 sur un
banc de sable au large du kent d'après
la légende le navire et apparaîtrait
tous les 50 ans entourée d'une lueur
verdâtre seul bémol encore une fois la
première mention de ce vaisseau fantôme
bien d'un article de journal de 1924 et
semble non pas à sortir des hommes et de
l'esprit du journaliste qui l'a inventé
les invention journalistique de ce genre
sont courantes et on pourrait aussi
citer l'exemple du marmot un trois-mâts
disparu dans les années 1890 est
retrouvé dans des circonstances macabre
ventes en plus tard à lire dans votre
supplément illustré du petit journal du
19 octobre en 1913 la suite va vous
surprendre
parfois pourtant les vaisseaux fantômes
sur leurs origines d'un vrai navire d'un
naufrage avéré c'est le cas du princess
augusta qui fit naufrage au large de new
york en 1738 rien d'exceptionnel jusque
là si ce n'est que l'histoire devient
une légende de la légende de 21,8 et je
vais arrêter cette citation du seigneur
des anneaux ici le navire aurait été
aperçu à plusieurs reprises depuis
enflammés entre noël et nouvel an nous
presser dans une tempête
ses apparitions enflammé de sont pas
rares on les retrouve dans la légende de
la baie des chaleurs ou un navire se
serait échouée au xviiie siècle
elle réapparaît très régulièrement sous
la forme d'une boule de feu il est vrai
que catastrophe maritime donne souvent
envie d'imaginer ce qui pourrait se
passer ensuite
entre deux eaux le naufrage du ss
valencia en 1906 et ses 136 morts donne
lieu à des apparitions imaginaire même
titre que le titanic a entraîné bon
nombre de légendes maritimes
au delà du désir courant de trouver une
explication surnaturel à tous phénomènes
inexpliqués comment comprendre ses
apparitions
comment expliquer les hallucinations
répandue dans une telle ampleur parmi
les marins et autres passagers des mères
on peut imaginer différentes hypothèses
mirage gaz inflammable remontant à la
surface
phénomène de bioluminescence ou feu de
synthèse qui provoque parfois des halo
entourant les navires mais l'explication
est parfois tout simple et nous permet
d'aller à l'abordage
dre laisse aux fantômes se clientes de
plus en plus les mères à partir du
xviiie siècle où justement avec le
développement du commerce international
les épaves dérivantes les épaves
dérivantes sont des navires abandonnés
souvent en haute mer pour différentes
raisons
il peut s'agir d'un incendie qui se
serait éteint ensuite d'un navire
prenant l'eau mais qui continue de
flotter après que l'équipage ray
abandonnés ou pire encore d'une maladie
qui se serait déclaré à bord qui aurait
tué tout l'équipage comprenant le navire
a flotté indéfiniment avec sa cargaison
de cadavres à mort heureusement ce cas
est plutôt rare
la seule fois où je vais retrouver dans
mes recherches dans les aventures
d'arthur gordon pym d'alan ball un roman
donc le bric venait à nous lentement et
avec plus de certitudes dans sa
manoeuvre et je ne puis parler de son
froid de cette aventure nos coeurs sont
follement dans nos poitrines et nous
répondions toute notre âme en cris
d'allégresse et en action de grâce à
dieu soudainement du mystérieux navire
qui était maintenant tout proche de nous
nous arrive est porté sur l'océan une
odeur une puanteur tel qu'il n'y a pas
dans le monde de mots pour l'exprimer
infernal suffocante intolérable
inconcevable j'ouvrais la bouche pour
respirer me tournant vers mes camarades
je m'aperçus qu'ils étaient plus pâle
que du marbre oublierai jamais la tripe
horreur de ce spectacle
vingt-cinq ou trente corps humain parmi
lesquelles quelques femmes gisaient
disséminés ça et là entre l'ariège et la
cuisine dans le dernier le plus
dégoûtant état de putréfaction
nous vîmes clairement qu'il n'y avait
pas une âme vivante sur ce bateau mouche
pour revenir à la réalité de nombreux
cas de vaisseau fantôme comme on les
appelle injustement existe donc le bail
qui mot était un cargo à vapeur
construit en 1914 est affecté au
transport des fourrures le long de la
côte canadienne
il est pris dans les glaces en 1931 et
contraint à l'abandon continue d'être
aperçu à plusieurs reprises toujours
pris dans la banquise différents
endroits de l'arctique et sa dernière
apparition remonte à 1969 il a
probablement coulé depuis le rio ou de
mar où repose lui aussi au fond des mers
à présent et ce chalutier japonais à la
dérive depuis le tsunami de 2011 n'est
retrouvé qu'un an plus tard large de la
colombie britannique
il est alors coulé par les garde-côtes à
cause du danger qu'ils représentent
le mv yobo orlova était déjà en piteux
état lorsqu'il disparaît en mer en 2013
puisqu'il était sur le point d'être
remorqué vers son site de démantèlement
et lorsque le câble seront il part à la
dérive jusqu'à aujourd'hui puisqu'il se
trouve toujours probablement quelque
part au milieu de l'atlantique dans tous
les cas présentés jusqu'ici on sait bien
où se trouvait l'équipage et la présence
de ces vaisseaux fantômes sur la mer
toutes dangereuses calais n'est pas un
mystère
dans le cas du mari céleste en revanche
on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui s'est
passé le 7 novembre 1872 le navire
quitte new york en direction de gênes un
deuxième navire le deuil grazia prend la
même route le 15 novembre au 4 décembre
entre les açores et le portugal
ils repèrent un navire qui approchent
azegza gants et sans ses voiles il
s'agit du mari céleste endommagé en
partie inondée vide et dépourvue de son
embarcation de sauvetage
la dernière entrée dans le livre de bord
date de neuf jours auparavant et indique
qu'il se trouvait alors à 740 km de là
et rien n'indique pourquoi l'ensemble de
l'équipage avaient fui le navire
emportant seulement des documents du
neuf
les instruments de navigation le mari
céleste et ramener en europe
il connaît un destin pas plus heureux
puisqu'il est échouée volontairement en
1885 pour une tentative d' arnaque à
l'assurance
quant à l'équipage de 1872 personne n'a
plus jamais entendu parler il est
probable que la chaloupe de secours au
milieu de l'atlantique et chavirer qu'il
ait terminé douaniers durant les
audiences pour déterminer les causes de
l'abandon du navire il a été avancé
qu'une mutinerie aurait pu avoir lieu
puisque des traces de coups et de sang
sont retrouvées à bord cette thèse est
reprise par conan doyle dans une version
romancée de l'histoire certains
soupçonnent même l'équipage de grazia
d'avoir attaqué le mari céleste ou
d'avoir comploté avec et d'autres
évoquent des phénomènes plus naturelle
comme une trombe pour expliquer la
présence d'eau dans les cabinets les
cales du navire ou bien le navire était
passé au dessus de l'atlantide qui dans
laxe entre le triangle des bermudes et
les pyramides de gizeh on connaît bien
ce genre de théorie
fait amusant un épisode de dr who may
consacré en 1965 dans flight to quality
[Musique]
une histoire semblable à rivaux carole à
dire ring une goélette qui faisait son
voyage de retour de rio de janeiro vers
la virginie le 31 janvier 1921 elle est
retrouvé échoué au large de la caroline
du nord l'équipage les instruments et de
nombreux effets personnels avaient
disparu avec les canaux de secours alors
qu'un restes de repas en cours de
préparation fut retrouvée dans les
cuisines
ce vaisseau fantôme a lui aussi entraîné
son lot de théorie et de fausses preuves
d'autant que pour le coup est passé
vraiment au dessus du triangle des
bermudes les autorités penchent plutôt
pour une mutinerie ou une attaque de
pirates
plus récemment encore puisque la sphère
date de cet été le sam râteau languit un
cargo indonésien disparu depuis 2009
s'est échoué sur un banc de sable ont
bien même sans équipage et sans
cargaison au port et il existe
énormément d'autres histoires sur ces
navires fantôme
mais encore une fois la plupart de ces
histoires viennent de sites absolument
fiables telles que creepy pasta from the
crypt ou mystérieux il connut tas on est
loin de la fiabilité historique mais si
vous voulez rire je vous invite à faire
quelques recherches sur le courant
meddah il ya même des photos montages
c'est magnifique face à la recrudescence
de tous c'est vrai navire fantôme qui
ont été abandonnés pour différentes
raisons et qui pose maintenant un danger
de taille pour les vrais navire avec un
équipage bien vivants qui fréquentent
les maires le gouvernement américain
décide de prendre des mesures
cette phrase était extrêmement longue
selon lui il y aurait une vingtaine de
ces épaves dérivant en atlantique nord à
la fin du 19e siècle et en 1908 lui scgc
seneca est mise à flot pour détruire ses
navires à grands coups dynamique
il en aurait détruit une dizaine jusque
1912 avant d'être assigné à la
surveillance des icebergs en atlantique
nord suite au naufrage du titanic comme
l'année dernière avec les revenants mon
propos ici n'était pas de vous faire
peur avec des mythes un vérifier mais
d'essayer d'aller au delà de ces
histoires de l'au delà qui fascinèrent
temps les pêcheurs du xviiie siècle
les lecteurs du 19e siècle et les
amateurs de clips et pasta du 21e siècle
les vaisseaux fantômes réels sont
injustement nommé puisqu'on y trouve pas
plus de fantômes que dans votre placard
enfin j'espère mais ils ont inspiré
tellement de légende marine qu'il
devient difficile de démêler le vrai du
faux
on peut tout de même retenir que comme
pour beaucoup de légendes marine qui
trouve une explication tout rationnel
dès l'instant où on fouille un peu sous
la surface des vaisseaux fantômes ou et
continue d'exister sans malédiction et
ce en font trop
je comble le film parce qu'il va bientôt
s'arrêter de fumer parce que il passe à
la doline suivante il n'y a pas de
bobines c'est un réflexe mais c'est pas
grave j'ai dit quand même je dis ce que
je dis je pense que je veux et je vis de
la mère de son truc bonjour je voulais
très mauvaise partie tant les maires
dans la laci une transe dont le q2 font
la beauté président le vaisseau de verre
l'aise mais ça je lutte mais les algues
mais en verre aux pierres de toile sur
les rochers pardon ce que je fais bien
l'air triste et choqué et déçu
heureusement ce cas est plutôt rare la
seule fois où je vais retrouver dans mes
recherches et dans les aventures denga
buzz d'arthur gordon pym on va dire
qu'il y en a eu sur des deux qui est
bonne on ne va pas tortiller du cul pour
chier droit jeudi du premier putsch
avait eu une fois quand je suis trop
fier je vais appeler ma mère ça rate au
lambi le sam râteau longue et on peut
faire et cette action le sam ratonnades
17 également échoué mais ça n'est pas la
mer à boire
plus récemment encore puisque la sphère
date de cet été le sam râteau lundi un
cargo indien il est indien ou pas n'ont
rien donné lieu il ya deux mètres en
plus dans ta phrase
selon lui il y en aurait une vingtaine
dérivant quelque part en atlantique nord
à la fin du 19e siècle et en 1908
j'ai failli dire dynamique mais je n'ai
pas dit les vaisseaux fantômes réels
sont injustement nommé puisqu'on y
trouve pas plus de fantômes que dans
votre placard
j'espère mais ils ont inspiré
je ne sais plus tellement les gens
marine qui devient difficile de démêler
le vrai du faux bond il reste deux plans
a d'abord on va faire un plan et puis on
va il
le tardis parce que les pas question que
je suis ma chronique de profs sont à 10
[Applaudissements]
min à